Ok so what is this and this is why. A lot of alleged. Lynage.
You know like a chain saw him in case he said at last you need to see why i didn't come to the aquarius festival.
I was working you saw him on i'm slimness. And i've lived here since. Permanently since seventy nine and.
I heard about him. I guess there must have been a lot of advertising or something like that.
Certainly people were talking about it. And i was working in funky. Vegetarian restaurant and.
We closed down side paper would have the opportunity to come up for the festival
and a mad man turned up with some pink rocks and.
That was that there was no choice i had thank god he charged up because from sydney and.
Camp and so on and i had a lot of mights from school and so on who were who were coming.
Because i'd left school before i think and. I was you know not using drugs. Copious amounts they're all for the.
The time that the restaurant was closed and. Then the restaurant reopened.
So i got the backroom thing and i think it was the first.
The first job that i'd ever had and the first consequences of my addiction.
But everybody else aim to have a really good time at the festival and. I ended up coming up a few years later.
I think god. My kid must have. About i. Months old and i came up traveling north and. And we started tumble.
And i remember trying to buy milk in the morning. Because we'd run out of milk. And i had nothin myself.
And i couldn't get anybody to say i'm not the woman who was in charge of the fucking cows wouldn't sell me an email
because it was about seven o'clock in the morning and she had a shit to do.
And i got so angry i was really pissed off and. I thought this is a really fall place.
And come back for about four years and then i met. Back up and down. But yeah.
My sort of experiences with sort of negative. In one way or another either not coming here or.
Getting pissed off with a lack of couse. Wasn't. Mohnish i'm sobbing.
So i'm cast some of the man like came up while i was. I came up to the fistula when the original.
Aquarius festival was a student at monash university at the time studying economics and politics.
I was really studying
when aleutian that's the miners know i'm going to moan i shall go away i was there was a high dive the mt the a.t.v.
It name and you can see. Depiction. Movements and. The five years of that thought seem to be coming from ornish.
Going to monash and. I hung in there for a couple of years and. When that came to an end.
That came to an end was at university the queerest fist of all our way into my figure by sidwell figured this was the
next direction of the revolutionaries. It was. Was headed into the hills. My. Today maker it was a bit dicey.
My drug consumption was sort of a sky thing off. Is the price for many this is the price health revolution.
And for the good laws and. I came up. Went to the festival. Went back to melbourne.
As well my staff and girlfriend and. And her up to this area headed up to this area and.
Moved in and basically i've been biased in this area of the scenes where you live for our border.
A share of the tunnel.
Lived there for a while or moved around it lived in nice been biased in a series of the scenes and.
It's hard to miss i mean i think if you're an addict manifest drugs. Like i mean a few.
And you have to do it and that's just reality. And so i mean i just did anything that i need to do.
To get drugs and a man in the alley dies.
It wasn't a diet a necessity i didn't have to have drugs on adani by so i could just you know occasionally.
Just this weekend use or you know. Be nice but you know it's more like been issues and.
In latter gys fortunate street culture and grown up enough so that one could arrest signed by susan.
And i could quit you know. So it wasn't. I mean once. That it happened it was.
It was a really easy thing to survive in terms of your addiction. Prior to that i surprised everybody get more rest.
You play or you go off and you get money. Yeah. One of them or.
One of the reasons i came out he was to get a wife from from. Narcotics as well as hard drugs.
And quite a few of my friends and a lot in the hills the sign raising where's their ideology quieted. Psychedelics is.
As cool and acceptable one part of part of the fight against the established while we did pretty early in the police.
To saved narcotics and alcohol and bobby to it's and pills as pretty much. Pool. Uncool as as as methods.
For the establishment. To control people.
And in the eyes died we were pretty one i mean we we knew about the say i smiling heroin out of their name
and we knew all that we knew all the connections and it was pretty to do. And what we're is.
We enjoyed the psychedelics we we didn't really feel comfortable with. Using. Using that colleagues and we did.
But once again that was a different contradiction there what that there wasn't with. The psychedelics and.
Yeah that was one of the reasons. On the doc he was to get a wife and that whole saying.
High street smart decision is an element of that time i want to actually hit on that it was harder
and harder to get the mind expanding drugs in melbourne and more of the hard drugs were coming in
and then we looked upon that is a means of pression a means of of wakening.
The sort of revelation i made and we felt was was happening in that time and.
I think i think it's probably going to be part of the. You know. Colleagues and high standards. History.
Drugs have picked a gentleman to saudi which are most likely to be trying to chime in a lot of people here get a life
from out here. Well a lot of it was that for me personally it's political after all the guy done.
Well for me it was basically trying to build. Become separate to become super economically politically socially.
To be independent. To not be dependent on mindstream society around. From it everything from a bicycle.
Material necessities to add to our cultural to our cultural consumption. Was to build an alternative system. I think.
Where we didn't really want him to say. I didn't perceive.
Any real likelihood of any violent revolution ever happening in a stride but i really thought that we could perhaps.
Build an alternative society. Which had a lot of guys that use that.
That i that i thought mainstream society lacked and side by sickly.
What we were about was trying to build a different system. In different schools. Different economy.
You know not plugged into the grid. And i'm not eating the sign food. I mean self-sufficient. And independent from an.
Oh. Again i think. Yeah. I think i think grass. Grass in particular was it was a great help for. A lot of table.
Model play with for a lot of people to get started up here. I mean people didn't have any money. There was no work.
There was no way to get a regular income people would go away and get a bit of a grubstake to get started. After that.
But then again i could do to supplement their income with social security or seasonal work and.
The extra few dollars that.
Little bit of grass boardin to the families was enough to get the cut the car reduced the engine.
The engine rebuild all the team for the roof. And i think the court a few people was a pretty integral part.
And it set that set.
Audiological it set pretty well with table because it was part once again of building a colony outside the mine strain.
I don't believe that. You know. Distinctions become involved or that.
You know any group large quantities of dots
and i don't think there was ever anything not the grass castle syndrome that psi happening with.
Because i think the ideology of the people engaged in the action.
The results in that you know if you want to fucking huge castles anyway. You know.
You want to just some nasty little house in the forest. I wanted good gardens.
Not be one of my next novel you want to have you know take video or anything like that everybody had a notion of.
You know leading a pretty sort of. Soundly principled life by stone. Like a nomics and. Son.
I mean it's somebody did manage to flu. To grow are like you know a few pounds of dog.
I mean nobody knew what to do with it. I probably got half of the wires that night so they.
I mean everybody smoked a lot of paper with sort of. I had apparently. You know i mean.
Welcome it was at that thing exchange to like i don't know anybody that i can think of.
Around here who who you know got heavy or grew a lot of dark
or anything not that my paper model just built really nice houses. But even that. You know a lot.
I did a lot of that themselves. And i'm out of employed and my to do some saw for. Whatever i don't.
You know nobody ever sat around up here. In their patches. With ruffles or.
You know rabbit traps or anything like that it was.
And i mean i think that sort of language is being all that sort of discourse has been engaged in
but i don't believe it i just think that that paper would like to imagine that sort of thing happening up in the hills
but it's certainly not a mark spear in sonoma and.
You know a lot of people growing dark for a lot of years and it just say. The people who were talked about as.
You know inverted commas. Grows are just people living in shacks.
Maybe sit on a pan of dark free here and that's this because the horror. Never perceived as a big growth industry.
Other than you know. A sustainable.
Kind of trip for people to just live on really simply sitting on the savanna which is talk to me in a process that's
for sure. I mean just the home. Night sure of the land up here and the amount of people names that basically.
People can get a wife would lodge with playing time the night of the laying and the amount of people around here and.
People can't get a wyoming. People don't grow crops some in the bag. Like residents have a strong family.
I mean that's. I mean large quantities of news been busted up here on the. Communion dollar drug bust.
Like somebody who's got four tries it's not in something say things like two inches high
and that i never knew that it is a full grown plant. There's never been the plantations that their family.
You know other areas where there's never been the organization i mean.
The people up here all bunch manik is something real in there.
That anything we haven't managed to organize with the defense of the forests and even that was very ad hoc
and of this really had hawken.
And that's what made it work sure you know like we were able to do that so well because everybody could just run around
in the forest and be chrisy by sickly.
I mean there was never that a courtly i sort of crummy not them about any sort of.
Saw him you ever got out he was totally disorganized. You know in a really small on a really small sky.
I mean isn't that the kind of crime that occurs in time like this it would be many.
There are not people running around stealing people's video.
Anything like that
and i mean you could probably argue that because this is a bit of a dive economy you know people can sign terms of
addiction support their habits here and i don't need to sort of go around.
Ripping off people's property or anything like that. It doesn't happen the drug problem is.
Well i guess that's the drug problem as i say that i said i think that the drug problem is you know.
A few sort of really skinny looking ferals and that's. I think people say the drug problem.
As very singular like it's just you know a few skinny girls hanging around outside the right about katherine that's a
really horrific drug problem whereas in fact nobody's being burgled. You know nobody's videos of thing tike and.
It's just that. We have one strange. Collins. With a couple of. Off shoots and.
People sit on the street outside the rhino or outside the museum or outside the tomato sauce.
And sometimes they pissed and sometimes they're on the nod and are not science a pretty much. But it's.
It's a very small time drug problem it's. It's not anything particularly serious and often.
You know i think that the people. Even on the not of peace they're just sitting there looking minutes.
And that will probably give the kids a lot of pleasure to sort of.
Be that many saying
and i know it must be really hard to be a little light in the shopping trolley walking down the street
and having to walk through that little bottleneck in front of the right.
And i've actually recently suggested that we extend the street skype so that.
There's several bottlenecks there rather than just the one and that way people can move.
At random through it and must be really scary because i don't know.
You know this kid's just tonight a new year old and he's just a good.
Whatever you know i just see him as a as a dirty threatening. And it must be really hard. And they're not they're not.
It's not king's cross. You know. And also i think the dye problem is is this cat fries used to describe.
Run a white kids. Homelessness poverty. Sauk patients who are being kicked out of half why hasn't got nowhere to go.
It's people we don't like it's. Drug problem is a drug problem. The other.
That is the drug problem marginalized and who haven't got any way to go and that we don't want here in our nice town.
We want. Town to be a fairly senate treetop. Plies. And i wrecked the landscape architecture.
Simply wouldn't say in terms of economics over poverty and homelessness i said in terms of the drug problem.
You know whereas a lot of those people haven't got a drug problem
and i just sitting there because they've got nowhere else to bloody sit and nowhere else to go and they've got.
I mean i don't have much in their lives. From our perspective.
But you know like you don't have to have much in your life when you're writing you just want to hang out
and hang around
and people say oh we'll say all latin rather than looking at the real issue is the fundamental issue is because of all
the media heart. Because of. Because of. You know the issue is that the best interests.
The vested interests are pushing in this town.
Always these complex social issues that are occurring everywhere out of the whole west and east
and well there is not just women. Has come under that the tardy problem of. The toddy hitting of the drug problem.
And i mean i think that's the hardest thing because people do. Do say niman as separate.
As a different place and that we shouldn't have these sort of problems here we should have some kind of. Idyllic.
Kind of recently and model of sucking.
Pastoral larf you know and it's ridiculous like we have this sign kind of problems that. Every you know.
Western capitalist nation has and i mean we're just we're just a microcosm of the kind of problems.
That other places have and i mean washroom.
Human being any different when that something that really irritates me actually. One of our private. Pit heights.
Is that people have this notion that. Newman. Is this fucking wonderful place and should be this sort of dream.
And that we're not we're just really ordinary people and. And the problems that we have a ordinary problems lot.
You know things like alcoholism and drug addiction and i have been everywhere the happening on a cholera
and the happening column straight and.
That's just the way it is and i mean i think there are really positive things that we can do about it.
You know such as you know halfway houses and.
Drug education i think it's really important to have drug education for tonight and.
You know workshops for them and i think it's important to have a lot of other things for our kids were a society here.
That is. Is going to have to buy. You know a lot of markets i chain. Hasten the although i can't agree.
My brother's girlfriend's. Twenty two. She's one of the first set of kids that went through and.
More and more like around the fourteen year old age group where my nephew.
We have a lot of a lot of kids coming up and i think that we need to sort of provide facilities for them.
Not just you know. In regard to sort of.
Drug and alcohol education or anything like that but i mean like we've got the youth club
and that needs funding i mean kids. In any country town. Night a lot of things to do and. Again. You know.
Different in that and.
Perhaps we can address things in a more creative mannah than other country townsmen we can give them better things this
new titles you know. But it's certainly something we're going to have to look at.
And i don't think you know that our kids are going to be any different must be kids are going to win lee.
Most of our kids want to get a gun and want to you know live in the cities and. Do the things that city kids do.
My sickly. So. Yeah i think that the nimbin miss is one that is carried in the hearts of many australians.
The post seventy's generation i mean. The call went out.
Didn't if we called it that those of us who'd grown up in the sixty's and.
And many answered that call you know people kind of in common i think ryan
and joined do a pretty good job of public publicize and.
I mean armistead unfortunately but that was my choice probably. And i mean people kind. And.
And i think people had a fucking good party.
They had a great party and that's probably all it was and i don't think that this is this.
Self-importance that takes place in the you know in people's minds with i well i have to sort of build up they used to
mike. Maining for something like that and and particularly who left. Does he just kind of the party.
I went to why and i wanted to say that i took place in something meaningful for once in their damn lives and.
And so you know this myth about newman grew up as. As you know the repository of file dreams or not you know and.
I mean i think it's really difficult for those of us who actually live here because people expect us to sort of the
hiving. In a certain why. You know to be some kind of. You know. Visionary society. To live out.
Does the ideals of the seventy's
and i mean basically it's the noughties i don't i don't see why i should have to live that anybody's vision.
Other than my own and you know my own vision news is you know i feel a small tomine personal
and i want living here it's a great place to live. But also. I don't see it in any.
In any novel terms and i don't say it in any particular idealistic terms and i do think that.
I do think that the personal is political and that you know you live out your politics in your logs and.
You can only do that in a really really small why in effect.
Those that are really close to you and i don't know i mean i think something really weird went on in him
and people who were probably really good at publicist
and i mean we've all got sort of fairly public skills you know people who sort of were trying to.
In the seventy's and i guess we've got the numbers.
I think that the paper kind of did develop a myth about what newman was and.
And its price and i think that it occupies a large amount. Then than it could possibly ever condon's.
I think that it looms large in people's minds. Really unnecessarily you know like it's just a place where people live.
It's a country town. And i mean most of us a fairly well educated who lives here.
And there was you know a real element of people who were very broad and very middle class.
Lives and so we probably got high in terms of brines a top heavy town. But you know that.
That's about it i don't think there's anything else going on here. Other than.
You know a few brought people sitting around having fun and living their lives and. There's still that focus.
I guess it's you know it's good for publishers it was good for the pay are in the seventy's when it happened in that.
You know there were a few nike tits and bottoms around and. You know we're still burying asked so.
To the national sarky a very high angle that people have to fucking listen to people about me when it's a story
but i think it's part of the human myth because basically a lot of people come here.
They've taken in the myth to heart and i come here would always expect tyson's.
About what i expected to them when it doesn't live up to their.
Their expectations to their dreams or their allusions by a blind man than by blind liminal by blind.
Driving a sideline or this whole thing that happens with people you know cycles for example move to the country
and think again the going to have this you know reselling model for a start they have to spend twenty four hours a day
together their kids are at home. With them often. You know the six or the vision of life.
Comes into play and then they last fall and. I split up. And then he's back to this. Having had a ghastly tell on and.
And again that line. What he thought. I mean we've lived here with ideals and i was on deals of chinese domain.
We came here with a lot of those original ideals and we have had to put those ideals in the practice
and what we've come up with a man twenty years down the line is. As a result of putting was.
Ideals into practice and they've chinese considerably and reality and. The reality of living here.
The reality of the chinese economic times and social tang's and growing alder and children. We don't use tobacco lives.
Toilet paper anymore than the chinese i mean you know we kind he we had these ideals originally as well
and i mean we just adapted to reality and. I'm in love guys on the menu just gotta live a normal life and.
I mean you can do that. You know with the praxis of china and yeah.
And just because just because the why we live these guys doesn't.
Doesn't come in saw it with a lot of people's sort of seventy's allusions about what alternative law should be and.
Because i say. You know. Feral savages and not noble savages on a sunday morning.
By then by then i think that the whole dream is filed and the whole thing is a disaster
but really it's just it's just china's not think of the fact that it's gone on and has adapted
and has adapted by simply prove that it's still a lot of unwell. And it's still growing. You know.
It's that time to fashion because seventy specially in flowing locks is really what people are used to in their peril
several. Comforts that people find that really confronting somebody the other day i got a lot of that some.
Some go had a. In this it was just like. I was so horrified that a really profound thought and again it's just like.
That is exactly the son's we were twenty min that's cool i love that that that. You know life can evolve and that.
Kids. I mean our kids have got something new to do rather than wearing you know. Born children. Less is that. I think.
Yeah. Stein. Yeah. Yeah well. Drugs were very large part of my life.
The thing for the first twelve or thirteen years that i lived here. And on every level.
You know a socially economically. But i was i were a large power and and. I think. I think on a good.
You know i don't regret those dies. I think that was good tons of those bad hons in those. Tragic tones but.
I think that was what i needed to get through to two. To spiritually grotty to evolve or maim.
That whole drug thing something that i needed to go through and come out the other end and then really.
There's something that i had to experience and it's. It was not good. You know. Cancel.
Judges all parents or anyone telling me. What was right and what was wrong and what was going to happen. By sickly.
Oh i had to go through it and went through it and coming out the other in probably a lot stronger and better off for.
Other people have and i mean other people dawdle on the one i was lucky. I think. I think.
Compared to a lot of my friends who stayed in the city. I think living in. Leading this involvement.
And in this community where the shoes were a lot more than and then discussed and.
Yeah i think on the i'll probably survive.
My addiction a lot better than a lot of my friends in the city did and i think.
You know on all levels on particularly health wise. I'm alison leigh. I wasn't as.
I wasn't as oscillated in the community here because of my diction.
I was always taken for who i was and what i did not the fact that i was just and that it was. This time and.
Not like now. You know attics of bill thaw and. Pretty much. And in the general society but i'm. In the alternative.
Community over the years when i was using. Not so much you're basically. If you're an addict i mean that that that.
That came second. To who you were and had your way in and. Yeah i think.
Oh i think i was definitely better off being an addict in the country than i was in the city.